this is why people are fed up with the
political class so number one secure the
board this isn't rocket science it takes
money it takes manpower it takes
technology but mostly what it takes is
to grow a pair and lead second to use
your phrase second you do we have to fix
the legal limit so glad to have this
next guest this is the first this is the
first hear on louder with Crowder we
have never had a politician on the
program generally because let me preface
this they usually send us a request with
talking points and I say I don't want to
do that and this was the opposite so
Carly Fiorina thank you so much for
being on well thank you so much for
having me and I'm really honored I
almost want to say to be your first
politician only I'm not a politician but
I am running for president that's true
ok I'm sorry there's a negative
connotation there I just meant you're
running for office and exactly and I'm
honored to be your first office runner
this is true I think we had a local guy
a while back but you know what that's
very that's something I'd like to lead
with you know I spoke with with your
assistants there of course you're much
more professional than myself it's just
me and Jared producing and I said listen
are there any things that I have to
avoid or I've worked with with people in
political office for a while should know
Carly's prepared for everything what is
is that is that just something that I
mean are you are you crazy or just that
well prepared well it's a couple of
things first of all I've been in and
around the world a long time and I know
what I know when I know what I believe
it doesn't mean I can't learn something
new it means that the issues that I talk
about are not talking points to me
secondly I'm not afraid of Who I am or
what I believe and so people have a
right to ask me whatever they'd like you
know Winston Churchill once said
something interesting he said there is
no such thing as an indiscreet question
only an indiscreet answer so I'm really
happy be candid with people when they
ask me questions that are interesting to
them although to be fair Churchill said
that before GoPros were invented I think
that could have changed his opinion a
little bit let me right off the bat you
know you seem to have a good sense of
humor about it I mean I'm not a
journalist I'm
an entertainer one thing I've noticed
contrary to everyone else out there
right now is instead of sort of beating
up on each other like Republicans are
doing you know you've been going
straight after the opposition Hillary
Clinton and I said we've coined you the
conservative honey badger is that a
conscious decision or did you say I'm
just going to avoid the sort of
muckraking as long as I can in the
primaries and focus on the real opponent
or is it is it just something that
happened organically well I think first
it's important to remember what this
fight is about
and I think 2016 is going to be a real
fight and we're in it already and it's a
fight between conservatism the values
and the principles and the policies that
I know work best lifts people up and a
Democrat Party that honestly has become
so extreme in its positions on a whole
host of issues that they are undermining
the character of our nation I believe
and also undermining the leadership in
the position of our nation in the world
not to mention destroying lives and
livelihoods of too many Americans
Hillary Clinton happens to be the
front-runner of her party right and so
if you're going to attack that platform
and that set of beliefs you got to
attack the person out in front telling
Americans that this is going to be good
for them when we know it's going to be
terrible right but I mean you the
noticeable difference between you and
say a lot of people who you know will
share the stage with you is well
everyone gets into like more Hatem
attacking Trump or attacking somebody
else you seem to focus in on on Hillary
and you seem to focus in on policy and
on the history of this administration
why do you think you're the only one and
I know the only one who's noticed this
who seems to be doing that now well I
don't know I can't speak for the others
I will say you know sometimes boys like
to have a fight you know but the real
fun issue the real issue is the future
of the nation I really believe that I
think we're at a pivotal point I'm not
trying to avoid your question no no
answer your I think we are at a pivotal
point I am running for office because I
believe we're at a pivotal point I think
this is a fight we have to win
we need a different kind of leadership
not just to win this election but
actually to put a leader in the White
House who will do the right things for
the nation and deed for the world on
that point you say boys like a fight you
will we will get letters through like I
can't believe how sexist that is and I
understand we recover I think you gave a
great answer on the view one that was
overlooked because the abortion thing is
kind of it was picked up but they asked
you about feminism and you crystallized
that I think in a way that resonates
with a lot certainly people like my wife
who would consider herself a feminist
but she can't stand what's newly been
coined third wave feminism this sort of
aggressive feminism you said a feminist
is anyone who makes a choice a choice
like I did to be CEO or a choice to be a
stay-at-home mom there's a really strong
you know we've I've talked about this
with some people who work with you
gamergate was a launching pad for a lot
of young Americans the politicization of
free speech right now a lot of people
seem to be rejecting the dogmatic
feminism but this includes a lot of
strong women do you think that was a
message that maybe was was lost on
people of the view and is it one that
you plan to focus on I mean obviously
going up against likely another woman
well I do think as I said on the view
that a feminist is any woman who chooses
her own life yes and we know there are
many many women in the world who don't
have that opportunity I do think the
term feminism has been politicized by
the left and indeed there are a lot of
left-leaning and left-wing women who
don't care anything about empowering
other women I mean for heaven's sakes
emily's list the pro-abortion group has
literally called
my candidacy offensive to women now you
know that's about ideology it's not
about making sure that women have
opportunities to do whatever they choose
to do and certainly whatever men do it's
about ideology and I think we do have to
continue to point out that the demo on
this way it's a party of such extreme
because it is a part that plays identity
politics you know you're a woman
therefore you have to care about this
and think this way you
Hispanic you have to care about this
issue and think this way about it you're
an african-american you can only care
about this issue and think a particular
way about it if you don't fit into their
identity groups and think the way they
want you to on the specific issue they
think you should care about then you're
sort of ostracized that's a terrible
thing and you bet we have to call that
out that's part of what I mean when I
say we have a fight on our hands really
right so I guess a big part of what
you're sort of putting in that same
number under that same umbrella feminism
is calling out the hypocrisy of leftist
women telling other women what makes
them a feminist
exactly it is hypocrisy it's hypocrisy
to say you're only a feminist you only
measure up in my eyes if you agree with
everything that I say and you know
Hillary Clinton actually said this she
actually said when she was campaigning
against Joni Ernst first woman senator
from the state of Iowa and for Bruce
Braley she actually said well you know
it's not enough to be a woman you have
to be a woman who believes and then she
went through the litany of left-wing
progressive views that she holds right
yeah and and that's something I do in my
view as a comic I would not be as
reserved as you are on the personal
front with feminism there's just a
litany of hypocrisy with Hillary Clinton
we won't necessarily get into that but I
appreciate where you're coming from and
that so let me ask you this in in
discussing the feminism thing I thought
it was a very funny sketch she did with
BuzzFeed I also thought it was smart
because it's an audience that no
Republican candidates that I know of are
reaching out to I thought you did a very
funny job but I know you're probably
where that BuzzFeed has pushed
microaggression theory they've pushed a
lot of really sort of honestly
anti-woman Pro third wave feminist
causes I got the sense that you were
doing a funny sketch but they thought
that maybe they were going to use it to
make a political statement if you look
at some of the writing in the comments
that you weren't necessarily intending
am I completely off-base keep in mind my
white male privilege is showing oh well
I wouldn't say that but look here's the
thing people can say whatever they want
to say you know that is part of what we
have in this
three free speech so people can
interpret something I do or something I
say they're free to do it I do think
this humor is and I applaud you for
being a comedian humor is a powerful
weapon to make a point you know I was
asked on a Saturday morning national
television show just as an example of
this I was asked whether a woman's
hormones prevent her from serving in the
Oval Office and my answer was can we
think of a single instance in which a
man's judgment was clouded by his
hormones including in the Oval Office
now by the way everyone laughs when I
say that and it makes the point
immediately it makes the point that yes
it's funny but the truth is it's
ridiculous to say that a woman's
hormones prevent her from serving in the
Oval Office just as it's ridiculous not
to acknowledge that there are certain
things that women hear that men don't
hear it's still different for women
that's a fact
no and I appreciate that because I think
it's sort of it's the same issue with
race right we're told by one side that
we just have to be completely totally
colorblind and then we're told by the
other side though if you recognize any
differences at all it's inherently
racist we're humans and I don't think
there's anything sexist about
recognizing the inherent differences
between men and women let's be honest
some things women are going to be better
they're going to naturally excel
compared to men and vice-versa I don't
know when that became hateful yes
exactly that's exactly right and my way
of saying it is this every single human
being has potential every human is
gifted by God I'm a conservative because
I believe that every person should have
the opportunity to fulfill their
potential to find and use their
god-given gifts that doesn't mean we're
all the same we're not all the same
but each of us has value each of us has
potential and we are all the same in the
eyes of God so in other words it hurts
us all if a group tential is not
fulfilled if women are underutilized
that hurts everybody the data is very
clear if we have too many African
Americans struggling in poverty not
getting an education and not having an
opportunity to move ahead in their lives
that hurts us all as well yeah I think
it's that that bigotry of low
spectators the soft bigotry but you have
it a lot well and I think by the way to
your point that is exactly the point of
this fight in 2016 because I believe the
core difference and I started to say
this on the view the core difference
before they interrupted yourself no no
no I always do before they ran out of
time Whoopi Goldberg ran out of time I
got very upset but it's the I think the
core of conservatism is no one of us is
any better than any other one of us each
of us has the capacity to live lives of
dignity and purpose and meaning I think
the core of progressivism of the extreme
left wing of the Democrat Party now is
actually some of us are smarter than
others some of us are better than others
some of you aren't capable of living
good lives so some of us are going to
take care of others and I think it is
the height of disrespect and disregard
and we need to call that out what's the
divide and conquer strategy of the left
and isn't it convenient that they ran
out of time if only she could have run
out of time as they were shooting Karina
Karina because that is what is truly
offensive to men and women alike a
travesty of film you're gonna get a
letter from Whoopi Carly I'm sorry you
don't have to you don't have to agree no
I told whoopee whoopee was our I have to
say what we was arguing with her
producer for more time she wanted to
hammer me on abortion for another whole
segment and I was itching for it come on
let's have this argument let's have this
fight yeah well Rosie Perez I mean when
she tried to rebut what you said and
listen you don't have to agree with me
here but it came across as though she
was barely walking upright in her
thought process it was no to you citing
the polls on I think it was abortion was
it past 20 weeks or 22 weeks I don't
want to misquote you it was one month
right once and I think and here's
actually something before we go to the
we'll go to the break because I want to
give you the floor to this after that
but you talked about that and right away
they go to abortion they go what about
it what about rape and incest right to
take it to the extreme case and I think
it comes down to whether it's a life or
not or not there are clothes handed
issues and they're open-ended issues and
then I think with both of those kinds of
issues there are closed handed ways to
deal with it and sometimes they're open
handed ways to deal with a closed
an issue that's confusing you can rewind
it we have this online Wickham with
abortion I know they try to go rape and
incest so that they can get you off
topic it removes it from the table I
thought you were very smart and saying
okay let's say we make exceptions for
that small fraction of abortions then
can we all find common ground on these
late term abortions on which the vast
majority of Americans agree and all they
could say is no I don't believe your
poll numbers well and and of course now
we have these Planned Parenthood videos
Roach actually have nothing to do with
whether you're pro-life or pro-choice I
know a lot of pro-choice women and a lot
of pro-choice men who are horrified by
these videos as they should be okay
Carly hold that thought we will be right
back
louder with Crowder she's classing up
the joint we will be back we are back
with Carly Fiorina of course running for
president if you haven't heard of her
you probably will after um I don't know
if it's appropriate to use any kind of a
murder comparison when it comes to
debates but every time I see Carly
Fiorina respond to a question in media I
think of that song with the bodies hit
the floor that's what pops into my head
I can't control it
I'm a male and I'm naturally aggressive
this is why I shouldn't be in office
Carly you were talking about the Planned
Parenthood videos I want you to continue
with that and I don't want to interrupt
well I said that this is not about being
pro-choice or pro-life this is about the
character of our nation honestly to
watch these women picking over babies
that's what these women are calling them
it's not someone else calling them
babies I mean there are people saying oh
look it's a baby oh look it's twins oh
look it's an arm and a leg this is about
the character of our nation
and to talk about extreme the Democrat
Party has closed ranks rallied around
and said absolutely there's nothing
wrong here there's nothing to see here
just go on go on go on and by the way
their extreme position is it's not a
life until it leaves the hospital that
is their position that it's not it
possibly
this thing can support that but so many
people don't know it because they wrap
it up in this baloney about women's
health and all the rest of it oh we're
doing breast exams actually they're
doing no such thing
right it's a series it's a web of
falsehoods designed to protect the
harvesting of babies body parts that
right there you can either take this as
an insult or a compliment as someone
who's worked with consulting when you
were talking about they say this that
was very off-the-cuff and seem like an
actual conversation
that's what I think attracts people like
me to someone like you now every
consultant there in DC would tell you
not to do that please don't change that
because I've never gotten that with any
other politician um we know what I
actually I really appreciate you saying
that because one of the things that I
was determined when I started this
campaign was never to sound like
politician most people are sick of
politicians I am too were sick of
sanitized sound bites and bumper sticker
rhetoric and the truth is people just
want to have a conversation because they
know there are really important issues
that we ought to be having real
conversations about that's absolutely
true and I was thinking about this today
and talking with my father about it I
think when running for office
I think hyper intelligence is overrated
I think you need to be smart enough I
think Ronald Reagan was a smart guy I
think if you were to put him in an IQ
lineup he probably wouldn't be the
number-one draft pick but I think he was
a smart guy but he was an incredibly
effective communicator sometimes you
need to Captain Kirk instead of a Spock
I think you probably have quite a bit of
both I think there are other people I
don't want to throw anyone under the bus
who's going to be on stage with you who
are hyper ly intelligent who don't
realize that they're not super effective
communicators I mean the guy who
engineered this computer on which I'm
speaking with you is not someone who I
probably want in office and that's just
one layman's point of view since we're
doing this inside is reaped preys on you
I'm gonna have to eat you with a couple
of hard balls but okay of course okay my
apologies
the nominal apology necessary well you
know it's it's that's the sexism in me I
want to be a gentleman but I also have
to do my job the knock against you that
you hear on too
if you have to get out ahead of this I'm
sure it'll come up as some people say
well tenure at HP wasn't as great as it
could have been what do you say to those
people what's your response because you
know that's what some people might bring
up you know I led hewlett-packard
through a very difficult time the
dot-com bust hos 9/11 the worst
technology recession in 25 years you may
remember that it's taken the Nasdaq the
technology heavy stock index 15 years to
recover - its dot-com boom high so in
that very difficult period of time yes I
had to make some difficult choices
nevertheless many of our competitors
disappeared off the map we didn't we
went from forty four billion to almost
90 billion in revenue we quadrupled our
growth rate we quadrupled our cash flow
we tripled innovation to 11 patents a
day most importantly we went from
lagging behind in every product category
and every market segment to leading and
the only way for a company to succeed
particularly in technology or for a
country to succeed frankly is to lead
and to grow now at the end of that
tenure I got fired I got fired in a
boardroom brawl that lasted two weeks
and you know why I got fired
because when you challenge the status
quo which is what leadership takes every
time leaders challenge the status quo
you can make enemies and sometimes those
enemies stab you in the back that's life
it's why so many people don't lead on
guarantee you when I am in the Oval
Office I will lead as well and I'll make
plenty of enemies but in the end the
problem with Washington is no one will
ever challenge the status quo and so we
have all these festering problems that
have been around forever and we have
been about forever and we talk about
them every election cycle and somehow
nothing really changes because no one's
prepared to challenge the status quo I
am I've done it and I know the
consequences I like crap expect you to
dance around that one a little bit more
so I p-taff a follow-up um I would say
good answer and hopefully people who
love those criticisms out there can take
it also I mean with HP - when I was a
kid it was basically kind of a printer
company and now they're selling smart
phones so it's changed drastically as
far as what they offer in
my lifetime well exactly and my mandate
was to transform a company that was
lagging further and further behind into
a leader we did that we did that I say
we because it was tens of thousands of
dedicated employees but transformation
change takes leadership it was my job to
lead a great answer and I know that all
too well with boardroom brawls and
politics I don't I don't do that well
with the back seven ground I get the
sense that you're not a backstabber you
look someone in the eye and stab them in
the face if they've really done you
wrong not literally not literally do not
take this literally people are going to
take that clip and say consummating
steps along the face um no but you know
to your point let me just say sure I
believe very strongly in character and
integrity I learned that from my mother
and father and to me what that means is
if you're going to say something behind
somebody's back you better be prepared
to say it to their face so I am prepared
to have honest disagreements honest
brawls with people but I will always say
it to their face that's a double-edged
sword though too I was talking with my
dad about this my wife is very strong
woman my mom is a very strong woman and
so I think that people like my father I
find ourselves attracted to you as a
candidate because that's what we seek in
a woman a lot of men can't handle that
not to sound like a social justice
warrior feminist here third wave
feminist but there are a lot of men who
can be intimidated by that and seek out
the opposite so do you think that's just
one of those things that's out of your
control and people will react how they
react because there are two different
kinds of men and some guys are going to
adore you and some guys are going to
head for the hills well I do think there
is there's a difference I'm not
everybody's cup of tea but what I've
found over the course of my lifetime is
I can gather enough support to get I
also think after peak times not every
fight is worth fighting it doesn't mean
you run around with your dukes up all
the time quite the opposite in fact
there are times when you've got to let
stuff go there are times when you have
to say you know what I'm going to set
this aside
for now and find common ground with you
and collaborate
there are times however I hate to cut
you off hold that thought can you all
right I said I hate to cut you off can
you hold that thought we have a hard
break here and I want to bring you back
cuz I know where you're going with it
and I like it I dig it Carly Fiorina
lotta with Crowder's stay tuned
or Carly Fiorina was going to make a
point we made her wait because we are
horrendous human beings please take the
floor and continue because I liked where
you were going well the point I was
making is there are is a time to set
something aside and focus on finding
common ground with someone there is also
a time when you've got to really sit
down with somebody and say we have a
major disagreement here these are the
things that I cannot agree with you on
in my experience even in that moment
there is an opportunity to find common
ground there is an opportunity for
collaboration but sometimes you get to a
point where literally there is no common
ground and there isn't an opportunity
and at that point you have to be honest
and walk away let me just bring that to
the world stage one of the problems with
this Saran deal is we never walked away
we never said we can't come to agreement
here this is a principle that we can't
bend on you know Anytime Anywhere
inspections for example we didn't say
sorry really have to walk away now this
is a principle upon which we cannot bend
and if you're not prepared to do that in
a deal in life in leadership then you're
going to get rolled you're going to get
rolled no that's absolutely true and
it's fun we were talking about this I
think last week we do find it funny that
you have leftists who want to take so
take away someone's revolver because
he's taken his annex at some point in
his lifetime but Iran with nuclear
capabilities or fresh on board what
could possibly go wrong there I can't
think of anyone less mentally stable as
a whole than the nation of Iran you know
it's funny I literally have this written
down and I don't write questions down
I'm going to read this for you word for
word I think a lot of candidates
compromise when compromise isn't
necessary but you need to find the
places where you can because compromise
and responsibility is hard bluster is
easy how do you draw that line you
basically just answered that
word-for-word
I guess to expand it out you need to be
prepared to walk away is there anything
else that you think is important in
drawing that line because it is
important to compromise and then also
not compromise when it's pivotal that's
right
that's right so I think there are three
cardinal rules to deal making and let's
face it compromise is making
deal okay you're compromising with your
teenager or the nation of Iran or the
opposite party compromise is about
making a deal to make a good deal I
think there are three cardinal rules
number one you have to state what your
principles your walkaway positions are
not at the end at the beginning you got
to go to people and say look this is
what I have to have I have to have it I
cannot compromise on it and then number
two you have to be prepared to put
everything else into the center of the
table in a spirit of truly willing and
open-minded collaboration but you have
to be clear about what your absolute
must-have principles and goals are three
you have to be willing to walk away
because if you don't walk away people
don't believe you will and they further
don't believe that you actually care
about principles and so if you don't
walk away my cardinal rule honestly I've
done a lot of deals in my life and my
cardinal rule always to myself and to
any negotiating team that I was the
coaching was if you haven't walked away
from the table three times you haven't
gotten the best deal you could it's just
how people operate they test they test
the limits we test the limits in our
families we test the limits with our
spouses we test the limits with our
negotiating opponent so you have to walk
away and then finally the last cardinal
rule that President Obama broke totally
is you don't celebrate the deal until
you have the deal you want so if you
celebrate a deal before you have one
guess what happens the other side keeps
negotiating and that's what happened
with Iran
I would really with you won everything
you just said except the concept of
compromising with a teenager I don't
think you ever come okay maybe I'll give
you that yeah then you end up with the
Clinton family so um listen again that
was me and I was not hurt here's one
thing that is concerning to me a little
bit I will say on a personal level I
don't think you said this to mean how it
came out but as someone who was raised
in Quebec okay parliamentary system
you're basically talking about mob rule
you talked on a recent program right he
remember exactly where it was we'll have
it up at the website about technology
engaging citizens with government I want
to be clear are you you're not talking
about governance by referendum are you
as opposed to
a representative Republic because that's
what I grew up with in Quebec and that's
immediately if ever we go to that it
sends up red flags because nothing gets
done and Quebec know what I am talking
about though let me give you a very real
example okay one of the things that I
think has to happen is we have to go to
zero based budgeting we actually have to
know where every dollar is being spent
so we can prioritize our dollars you
know we're not today which is why
government just gets bigger and bigger
and more and more inept so I would go
into the Oval Office and a weekly radio
address just as an example and I would
ask people to take out their smartphones
and I would say I'd like to ask you a
question do you think we should know
where your money is being spent press 1
for yes two for now people will vote
what does that do it signals to their
representatives this is an issue we care
about this is what we think ought to
happen we know that politicians in the
political process respond to pressure
it's how we got Congress in three short
weeks to pass a bill that said people
could get fired at the VA if they didn't
do their job of course they haven't
fired anyone but it was this massive
amount of pressure from people saying
guess what we care about this you've got
to be able to fire someone the point is
ours was intended to be a citizen
government citizens need to be engaged
in the process of their government and
technology gives us the tool to engage
citizens directly in the questions that
matter to them so that their
representatives can respond to what
people really think we don't need
pollsters telling us what people think
and we all know their issues with polls
huge issues with Paul's sure people can
actually tell us what they think that
that would be good to know okay a couple
of things that you just brought up you
were talking about voting YES hit one
for yes two for no in Florida they would
mash it with their palm and then demand
a recount
which brings me to Jeb Bush you talked
about polls here's something Carly and
you may like the the guy you may not I'm
not a huge fan of him as potential
president that's my opinion I don't know
him personally but I don't know anybody
Carly and I know a lot of people and my
producers don't know anybody and no one
in my family knows anybody we don't know
a single person not one who jeb Bush's
their guy how in the world does he lead
in any poll because when I talk about
that
you hear an outcry on Twitter of people
saying they don't believe in the primary
system they think it's rigged they think
conservative media is trying to
manipulate it just as bad as leftist
media tries to manipulate Nationals and
I don't tend to chalk up to I guess
collusion what could be chalked up to
incompetence but in this case when I
don't know a single person with JEP how
is there such a discrepancy well because
I think it depends a lot on what polls
you're looking at so let's just take
this debate tonight Fox News decided to
use national polls
what national polls at this point in a
race are measuring really his name ID
right because there's so many people who
aren't paying attention yet if you go
into state polls a Florida pull a four
toll and Iowa poll a New Hampshire poll
you'll see very different results than
the national polls because they're
talking to people in those states who
are actually engaged and who are going
to vote a national poll measures
basically name ID so guess who has the
highest name ID in the field Donald
Trump guess who's next
Jeb Bush yeah can we talk about Trump or
do we not want to talk about Trump sorry
I just so sorry I just made it
horrendously uncomfortable okay Trump
has been a catalyst here for the illegal
immigration issue now not tactful I'm
not convinced as a conservative we have
a lot of I mean when you have Clinton's
front and center at your wedding when
you give six figures of the Clintons
when you're literally a card getting
Democrat for most of your life I'm not
convinced
I do think you served a little bit as a
catalyst for some issues where maybe
he'll allow some of the candidates who
are a little bit namby-pamby to grow up
there that's my opinion maybe he'll
serve that role um some people might say
you're not as hard on on immigration as
someone like a trump who I haven't
really heard all for an actual solution
clarify your stance so that no one else
is misquoting on immigration
what would a carly fiorina
administration do what i have said
consistently all along is number one we
have to secure the border by the way how
long we've been talking about securing
for thirty years I mean to be accurate
the border has not been secure for
thirty years we've been talking about it
for at least twenty five it's still not
secure so what does that tell you it
tells you politicians talk talk talk
talk talk and yet it never
yes done sanctuary cities you know how
long San Francisco's been a sanctuary
city since 1989 everyone's going to get
all fired up about this they're going to
give speeches you're going to pass laws
and yet nothing really changes this is
why people are fed up with the political
class so number one secure the board
this isn't rocket science it takes money
it takes manpower it takes technology
but mostly what it takes is to grow a
pair and lead second to use your phrase
second do we have to fix the legal
immigration system how long is the legal
immigration system in broken how long
have we been talking about it 25 years
25 years we've had over 16 different
visa programs we have an e-verify system
that doesn't work really in 2015 we
can't create an e-verify system that is
working that is mandatory we're handing
out border crossing cards every single
day over the Mexico border you're
supposed to come in for a day in return
home well nobody checks this is an
example of ineptitude or the disregard
of the political class of issues that
really matter and finally I have said
equally explicitly that I don't think if
you've come here illegally and stayed
here illegally that you get to earn a
path to citizenship ever you may earn
legal status at some point but there has
to be a reward for people who study our
history take the oath raise their hand
understand that citizenship is a
privilege to be earned there has to be a
consequence for those people who play by
the rules I have said this from day one
over and over and over as well from made
this issue popular but make no mistake
loads of Republican politicians many of
whom are running have not fixed this
problem in 25 years and we can't blame
it all on the Democrats because we've
had Republicans in the White House we've
had the majority in the House and Senate
people go along to get along the status
quo hasn't changed whatever your issue
or cause whatever festering problem you
hope would get solved political classes
failed us actually bodies hit floor
Carly Fiorina thank you so much we know
you're busy we'll let you go Godspeed
and hopefully we'll check back with you
and that name ID situation will change
I'm bettin that it will thank you thank
you I really enjoyed it have me back we
will have you back there we go you saw
it so she this is like a verbally
binding contract we didn't scare Carly
Fiorina aw thank you so much Carly we
will have you back and really we are we
are going to be watching this like a
hawk thank you all right take care
Lauder with Crowder stay tuned if you
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face or watch one of these videos next
to me if you don't I'm pretty sure
you're gonna flag it as hate speech you